[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants mais qu'est ce que
tu caches derrière ton dos nounours
orient survenant au trot ou bien tu sais
que je ne suis pas curieux servian pas
trop sais rien mon le cheval ce sont des
images pour les enfants sages quel gros
cachottier ces nounours pop hip hop hop
hop hop hop hop au bon soin j'apporte
des images pour les enfants sages
eh bien ces images sont pour vous c'est
sur cette image fait dans ce tour
déroutant qui a construit ses jolies
maisons mais alors c'est comme dans la
chanson dans la chanson tu es bête dans
la chanson de café rochelle
oui et nous allons la chanteuse et moi
j'suis carrousel
cadet roussel à trois maisons qui n'ont
ni poutre niche france c'est pour loger
les hirondelles accueillir et vous de
cadet rousselle enfin kader où seuls à
trois amis salle a3 à baa2 jour le lot 3
papier il mais celui-là quand il gèle ou
quand il pleut ou quand tigre est le
[Musique]
généreux seule et bonne enfant cadet
roussel à trois gros chat la cour liev
l'autre au lapin troisième son fils
quand on l'appelle à des rouges elle ne
m'aura pas car avant de sauter le pas de
sauter le pas pour faire lui même sans
d'épitaphe
c'est vrai il lui ressemble ou benquet
de russel vasco chez tu viens notre mère
oui côté kader sienne enfants là
j'éteins la lumière veux te bourrer
gardien kader hussein alors nounours
vous êtes vous bien amusé et on a chanté
cadet rousselle pas trop moi j'aime
tellement chanté mais je préfère l'opéra
le vaudois est toujours tabou tant mieux
et bien en route nounours bonne nuit des
enfants prodiges
m
où
avant
[Musique]